a lot of times when we have a specific
piece of communication that we need to
do we run over and we open up PowerPoint
and we just start to think linearly well
you're like okay slide once like this
I'm going to go grab six slides over
here to from this deck to it we
Frankenstein this thing together and we
jump up and then we present and we think
that that's effective communication and
it's not in reality what you need to do
is think about your audience just obsess
about the audience and then think about
stories and ways that you can make a
heart-to-heart connection with them
think through what the one big idea is
you want to convey and then you build
all the content around that the most
important thing to remember when you're
building out your slides is contrast you
need to prioritize for the audience the
order in which they're to process your
information so you've got to think about
how their eye is going to flow across
the information what's the most dominant
thing so what's primary what's secondary
what's tertiary information you can use
colors to do that you can use shapes to
do that you need to simplify everything
because if you think about the concept
of contrast you can think about its
opposite which would be camouflage right
right now in slide decks everything
looks the same there's not one dominant
thing and there's not everything else
secondary to that so if you think about
camouflage and you look at every slide
as if you're trying to minimize the
amount of camouflage to your idea you
can actually find that one key thing
that you're trying to do and just
amplify that by using a big contrasting
color or making a really minimal color
palette making that one thing pop out
it's really important that it pop the
one idea so every slide should have one
big idea and you need to make sure
visually that that one big idea is
amplified and not lost in the mire of
your speaker notes
one of the things that's happened is we
use PowerPoint two ways you could use it
as a visual aid or a cinematic backdrop
to support your idea when you're onstage
presenting but the other thing that's
happened is it's become our visual
document tool instead of people running
out and getting these very expensive
design programs we're designing our
documents in corporations in PowerPoint
but the flood and that's great you could
use it for your cinematic you could use
it for your documents but the problem is
we're in this weird blurry in-between
thing where it's kind of this mix
between a document a teleprompter thing
and it's got tons of text and then what
happens is you show up to an audience
you turn your back to the audience and
you're hosting a read-along well the
audience can read faster than you're
spewing out the bullets and they're
thinking this guy's idiot I already know
everything what he's saying because I
already read ahead we don't want that to
happen to you so you want to make sure
you're either either using it as a
visual aid or as a document if you're
choosing to put a ton of words on it and
you're choosing to use it as a document
distribute it as a document talk about
it as if it's a document but don't stand
up and present your documents to an
audience